welcome everybody to the h3 podcast
experience we have a fantastic show here
for you today
we've got PewDiePie Adele big Edie
Skippy butter pecan pie is not here but
we are traveling by by freight boat
he'll be here in 30 days
today's episode is sponsored by Adam and
Eve Ridge wallets and hims all right
thank you everybody for joining us how's
everybody doing today dan and Zach ela
how is everybody
who goes first chillin yeah you dressed
all of us at once I'm dead everybody say
oh they're doing three you know one okay
when I come in Cedar Rapids all right
when I count down I'm gonna say five
four three two one and oh one everybody
tell me how they're doing at once ready
5 4 3 2 1 how's everyone doing we got to
rehearse that so when I asked everybody
guys on Twitter I'm giving away a ton of
money we're on day 26 of help I'm giving
away $1,500 every single day on Twitter
to help define people of the h3 nation
so there's still 74 days left so get on
that we've given away like thirty five
thousand dollars so far also on Teddy
fresh we got some classics back and
stocked the Bubblegum hoodie TF hoodie
and joggers and the embroidered t-shirt
a fresh calm I would like to get today
started by talking about tick tock now
tick tock you know tick tocks been
around and arising for a long time but
to me is I see a lot of dancing and a
lot of nonsense but what I'm starting to
see more and more that I'm loving is
this print culture they found a new
place right it's like all these
pranksters find the lowest common
denominator [ __ ] where their content
can spread like cancer and people just
consume without asking anything
and so and so tick-tock has really
become a place where this kind of
absolute trash flourishes and I just saw
this video recently they just just took
my breath away frankly by how bad it is
if you guys know of any other tick-tock
videos and you guys - uh in the cast
keep an eye out because I love this oh
this was removed from trashy it was too
trashy for the trashy subreddit it says
moderators removed this post for a
variety of reasons including keeping the
community safe civil and true to their
purpose how do you get to trick your
true trashy for tragedy bro that's crazy
alright I'm gonna play it through and
you guys so a guy approaches two friends
sitting at a table he grabs one of their
phones smashes it on the table breaks it
then they're like what the [ __ ] dude and
he's like sorry man
here's a new phone it's just a prank
that's it
for your iPhone's I'm so sorry but we're
over praise what the but you literally
shattered my phone yeah we saw is this
the worst video ever made it's the worst
video there's a good chance it's fake
and if it's fake it's still the worst
video ever made it's even worse because
they could have made it better because
it's fake you planned that and it's like
his reaction is so pathetic sorry bro a
bit of video where it break your phone
give you a new one but I do think
there's a good chance it's real actually
as well because the reaction is just
[Music]
that guy how quickly it decides to open
the lid of the coffee and spill coffee
on him is that confuses me if it's real
or fake I'm gonna tell you I actually I
used to think this was real but I'm
changing my verdict and let me tell you
he's so rehearsed on that he's like
first of all who throws coffee at
somebody it's such a like girl thing to
do in a movie like take the lid off it's
a roll of coffee on somebody how is that
your first impulse it's crazy
I don't think that would break the foam
here's necessary if you really want to
break funny able to smash it on the
ground as hard right
also notice the box were were
scrutinizing this video way too much but
notice the box look super light as well
look how light the box looks you can
kind of tell us that like when he hits
it it sounds Hollow that thoughts what
do you guys think I'm leaning towards
fake but I'm a little on the fence the
guy's reaction when he calls him a
weirdo it's so good it's pretty it's
pretty good acting of its fake which you
don't usually see in these videos I mean
the way he says it sounds pretty
authentic but but elements that you
pointed out to make me lean towards fake
well because it's such a word that to me
is the only thing real about it you're
such a weirdo bro we should sound bite
that sack would you think the throw
coffee on somebody in response to I mean
the lid off thing like Yili said yeah
that seems waiting there do that
I got a counter-argument oh we thought
well what about the fitly offensive we
thought for a minute he was real - I
know and I totally screwed up on that
one I learned my lesson you're right
Zack sometimes you just don't know and
that's why we need to screw
nice the worst video ever made for like
20 minutes I wish we had a fairly
offensive here to tell us cuz he would
probably know but ultimately I'm gonna
cast my vote on this once and for all
you really shattered my phone and the
way who's respond is so pathetic like
how could that be rehearsed oh sorry
why would you rehearse that bro I'm so
sorry I just I'm doing a tip-top video I
break your phone and give you a new one
it's so hard to tell it's so hard to
tell nobody acknowledges the cameraman
either right I mean you have to
acknowledge that I can't decide hey vote
fake gotta tell ya it's probably fake
which is so sad it's so sad that it's
fake well there you go guys uh if you
have more tip top videos like that I'd
love to I love to watch more of them
another clip that I thought I would
enjoy here with everybody today is you
know everybody's doing the news from
home yeah which looks so pathetic cuz
when they're in their studios with all
the cool green screens and these amazing
studios and their crazy cameras they
look so slick and professional but from
home the news / zoom it took it it
doesn't impress me it doesn't feel like
it's just lost its luster everything I
mean like the nightly news we're some
dude because I found in a weird way that
I enjoyed them more know their late
nights
mm-hm hi found that too because there's
no laugh track the audience ruins
everything live audience sorry guys
let's watch this anyway do you trip a
little bit take some of your profits
because what is it you never go broke by
taking profit you never go broke by
taking profit
homie is just sitting upright dead
asleep but apparently my comma Sigma
left guy speechless watched you get my
target and he's so much money in the
name if you voted they turn him off yeah
they must there's someone like Dan in
the back because they term up about
trading and I'm sure he's not wearing
pants you know they may I could just
tell by the way his jacket said
something that he's not wearing pants
see this is where they failed they
should have left the sleeping guy up
yeah and then we would have gold so
there you go obviously we bring you the
greatest entertainment on the planet and
we will continue to next story is about
PewDiePie he's in the news everywhere I
don't know why people are making such a
big deal about this I guess it's just
PewDiePie I think what it is PewDiePie
signed an exclusive live streaming deal
with YouTube I think what it is is that
it's like a reconciliation between
YouTube and PewDiePie that they've
written they've they've reimbursed
PewDiePie into the fold and I think
that's why people are loving this
headline they also put him in the recent
YouTube rewind so I think that maybe
this beef is squashed finally between
YouTube and and YouTube's darling
PewDiePie I don't remember but they did
do you remember what they did they did
like they just did stats I never liked
this [ __ ] is so boring
right hello shredder oh god nobody
breathe we'll just do a cut of course
when the media recorded it will there
ever be a time when the media can cover
anything PewDiePie related and not say
like give a laundry list of his race
races history look at these headlines
Forbes PewDiePie signs deal with YouTube
despite history of races anti-semitic
comments yeah I just I do feel bad for
him it's like damn how long ago was that
at this point Washington Post PewDiePie
YouTube's controversial but popular
creator signs exclusives for me deal
yeah I don't know but I actually have to
say I'm happy that PewDiePie decided to
do it with YouTube and not twitch
because I've personally just in my
experience streaming on both of them I
found YouTube to be a better partner and
I think the competition is good too you
know there's a lot of shenanigans on
Twitch and and I think the competition
is good you got to keep twitch on their
toes so congratulations to my my what
what does pewdiepie he's I don't
hesitate to I mean to my good dude
PewDiePie on his exclusive streaming
deal alright anything else my friend I
think I could call him a friend but I
mean the frankly we don't talk that much
we do talk occasionally and we are
definitely friendly but I would hesitate
to call him a friend just in that I
don't want to overstate necessarily like
closeness or anything yeah cuz I think a
friend denotes like regular contact
right sure
the term become friendly we're
definitely friendly what Zach call a
confidant would that be this a
confidante hell no no no unfriend yeah
call phone is someone you tell your
deepest darkest secrets to no never mind
that's like a deep that's like a war
buddy what I find interesting about this
story about PewDiePie is someone you can
fight in that's where it comes from the
guts I'm just so sorry down the story
about PewDiePie this comes on the heels
of remember like a year ago he started
streaming on that weird-ass d-line thing
yes and nobody seems to be like talking
about that at all I'm still
so confused by that and that whole thing
remember it was like a blockchain base
yes screaming service with like you're
so right cryptocurrency built into it or
something it's like so weird yeah that
must have been I'm just taking a wild
stab in the dark here deal I've ever met
that [ __ ] is so weird
yeah it doesn't make any I think that
must have been during a time when he
couldn't get sponsors from anyone
and then the Bitcoin people companies
yeah the crypto comes in they're like
what's want to you know okay that makes
some sense that's the only feasible
explanation because he would have
definitely worked with twitch are you
two dealer yeah d-dad more like alive
and see if anyone's on that it is here
it looks exactly like twitch like how do
you know that's the smallest detail
anytime someone offers payment crypto
I'm like oh I'm being scammed right like
immediately I mean there's not a ton of
people on this but chatting 19,000
watching I don't know is it true well D
live if you uh whoo well hey I'll take
some Bitcoin anyway yeah they just they
just lost their biggest person so do you
live I don't think they can compete with
YouTube that must've been a nice juicy
deal for him though so congratulations
to Felix translations on his huge deal
and and and really [ __ ] Rican selling
reconciliate in with youtube I think
it's about time that these two powers
come back together I mean it is the
biggest channel on YouTube you can click
on it's kind of funny to ignore ela are
you is the second-biggest channel yeah
are you really is that racism i
[Laughter]
[Music]
individual driven personality driven
channel what would be fair to say that
would be fair what was the name of my
channel again the Indian media company
yeah these series bro yes wait how many
subs as T series have no more than
beauty by oh yeah but I wonder if how
they took it away oh how far it's gone
yeah let me see whoa you never shot 138
million subscribers these guys don't
quit man T series is going for like when
you're old pumping out quality content
like that all the time is you're bound
to find success well I'm not allowed to
talk about Indian people or Bollywood
anymore
I was revoked my Bollywood card was
revoked yes it is sorry go ahead
did we ever talk about that controversy
on the podcast no we shouldn't and it's
in its sponsor time okay Adam and Eve
Adam and Eve is sponsored our episode
today it's the number one adult toy
superstore Adam and Eve says the best
part of staying at home is playing at
home if you know what I mean they've got
toys for men toys for women couple have
any one have only you guys ever used a
flashlight no so gonna set Zach yes yeah
which one did you get a mouth or a
butthole or a badge was a vagina it's
just the ones with the mouths I've seen
photos it's just so funny cuz it's like
just a detached mouth in a flashlight
and you're just like Adam and Eve but
they've got those if you like them I
don't know if they do maybe they do but
they have toys for men toys for women
couples toys every kind of Lube and
lotion a man or one we could dream of
lingerie and so many other sexy gifts
take advantage of the downtime and
choose almost any one item and get 50%
off at Adam and Eve calm when you do
you'll also get 10 free boredom busting
gifts including 6 spicy movies 3 piece
bonus kit and best of all free shipping
too
livered discreetly right to your door
mmm I noticed these are very cryptic all
right six spicy movies and three piece
bonus kit just remember to use offer
code h3 that's HTTP a check up for this
amazing deal Adam and Eve has thousands
of products to make you glad you are
staying at home sex toys make being at
home so enjoyable in fact shopping from
home is more enjoyable when you're
shopping for sex toys go to
adamandeve.com and use that offer code
h3 to get 50% off just about any item
plus 10 free gifts use h3 at checkout in
where are you yeah I'll just
even just walked off I was gonna ask if
he ever put his dick in anything weird I
guess now I guess I'll save that
question for another day it was coming
dan have you anything no next up we've
got Adele she was a little so Adele's a
singer she's a little she was a little
chubby
is that insult I mean she's a little
chubby that's fair to say okay she went
into quarantine and she posted this
picture on Instagram of an incredible
weight loss transformation and she looks
fantastic she looks happy she looks
healthy you know let me show before and
after here you know just being specific
so the internet knows what I want like
yeah she was pretty chubby right I mean
so so here she is and then here she
comes out and I'm like wow she must I
mean so everyone would be like wow Adele
you look fantastic
everyone's so happy for you and the
reaction that some people had was just
was just incredible people were upset
that people were happy that she lost
weight because they're saying you're
implying that she wasn't beautiful and
happy but
while she was chubby and I don't know
why we have to pretend like on the whole
let's say let's put this let's put this
Adela kitty on the whole people who are
chubby are less attractive generally
speaking to most people can we say that
can I say that do it does everyone agree
with how I phrased that I mean sure yeah
yes man when a yes people let me speak
for myself okay let me address these
people I'm I'm fairly chubby now when I
was skinny and fit I felt better more
confident more attractive you just feel
better it's better it's just it's for me
and my experience that's just better and
so complimenting and encourage people to
be healthy and feel good it's just it's
strange but okay let me read some of
these tweets please stop saying Adele
had a glow up we have no idea what her
health was is like and this is just
reinforcing the skinny ideal or the
concept that skinnier you get the
prettier if you go I mean generally
speaking invited by this is 8 mm mics I
just I don't get it
I just find the whole thing so funny
because she's already proven that she
can do anything she wanted before she's
super successful
she made it while being overweight so
that stereotype she already proven wrong
like it's not like people told her okay
you want to be a singer you got to lose
30 months which is what it used to be
right and that's why people do have a
problem with you know that's a weight
issue but she's already lived through it
and made it she's huge like famous why
physically no you say that she was
chubby I wouldn't say she was huge
[Laughter]
she goes we have no idea what our health
is was like I know what our health was
it's not good when you're chubby it's
not there's no there's no such thing as
healthy fat people I'm sorry
the skinny ideal our concept is skinnier
you get the prettier get I mean
generally speaking the skinnier
you get the prettier you got now there's
a difference of course between being
anorexic and healthy
she's clearly healthy what the [ __ ] are
we debating this is self-evident I don't
get this let's continue can we please
not celebrate Adele for losing weight
like it's the ultimate achievement it's
very difficult to lose weight when
you're fat yeah it's super it is a great
achievement it takes a ton of work and
dedication to do that she goes the news
and articles and tweets are disgusting
seventy five thousand likes why why are
people endorsing this I think it should
be celebrated it is a huge achievement
to lose that much weight it's so
difficult have you watched my 600 pound
life losing weight is like an addiction
I mean these people are it's like [ __ ]
it is why are you demeaning her
achievement it is it's so hard to lose
weight as a fat person it what the [ __ ]
what the why is she demeaning her
achievement why I feel like this tweet
is very rude to Adele my whole she
continues my whole entire platform is
about positivity self upset acceptance
inequality I refuse to let my words be
twisted ruin all my hard work
as someone who has constantly had their
worth defined by the looks I was born
disfigured but but I don't wasn't she
she is successful despite whatever
figure it's not like you know she
decided she wanted to lose weight and
she did it she was already successful to
me that I think that's a fantastic point
it wasn't such a society societal
pressure she decided on her own after
having been a successful female
performer that she wanted to get healthy
I see that at Delos training because
people are saying how gorgeous she is
since she lost weight y'all been over
this y'all we've been over this I
decided this for everybody your weight
doesn't determine your beauty your
parents doesn't determine your beauty
the number on the scale doesn't make you
worthy or unworthy anyway that's it I
was just shocked i I thought she looked
fantastic I was very happy for her
I just think it's and I
found and also you think it's so such an
overreaction because she posted the
picture she is happy for herself and
then people will have before her like
that's all there is Darren and it
doesn't need to be anything more than
that well apparently she didn't even
comment on the weight loss she
disappeared from social media she said
thank you for the birthday level I hope
you're all staying safe and saying
during this crazy time I'd like to thank
all of our first responders and
essential workers who are keeping us
safe so she didn't even comment on it
but clearly she cares about it if she's
doing it and it's hard despite what
these people want you to believe very
difficult so there you have it her
personal trainer also made a post he's
like what is wrong with you all in short
um god man I think that part of the
negative reaction I suspect has to do
with the fact that she was one of the
most sort a is one of a successful
musical artists in the world and is a
bigger girl and was probably you know a
hero to a lot of people that are
overweight because of that you know what
I mean that it's probably part of her
not necessarily her appeal but it's just
part of our identity and it's part of
you know her story of success and
everything right exactly and you know I
could see that some people maybe feel
even if they don't admit it betrayed on
the level you know because it doesn't
that so that that insinuates that people
should be happy being obese and i don't
think people should be happy or
satisfied being obese and i don't think
you are happier satisfied man i think
people who are obese know that it's
unhealthy and it's brutal because the to
maintain that level of fat you need to
be you need to be just every day making
bad decisions with food and and and you
feel like [ __ ] she was yeah i think she
was obese I mean I mean yeah by the
medical definition of it
probably she was I mean here she here's
a pic really when you think of a PC look
of people that are like huge but she's
obese bro look at that she was she when
she lost like a hundred pounds it looks
like I know obviously it's a good thing
and and you know you know that she just
had a kid too and I think that's what
B's sorry you know but that's obese
sorry good thing she had a kid and you
know a lot of people when they have kids
they wake up to their their own health
because they want to be around for a
long time for kids and it has a direct
impact on that so yellow obese okay I'm
just I'm trying to get you to admit
she's obese but obese to the technical
right that's true that's amazing though
anyway congratulations to her and and
anyone who's offended by the fact that
people are happy for for losing weight I
don't know what to say to you but I hate
but I don't like you okay moving on next
it's a pretty sad reality when you can't
even be happy for someone for something
you know I think that's why it's so
frustrating
what are they what do we know just happy
for her are we not supposed to
acknowledge it like oh cool hi like how
shitty would she feel did they not even
notice that I lost hundred pounds what
Dan I was gonna say we're uh probably a
second ad return okay well that's great
because I'm happy to talk to you guys
about the ridge wallet folks look at
this I'm a guy I hate the bulky wallet
and put put in my pocket I wear elastic
waist pants and it was always pulling my
pants down it's just chunky I don't like
it it's the Costanza wallet I don't like
it that's why the ridge wallet is the
genius wallet that is revolutionizing
how we carry our [ __ ] around money clip
boom there's your cash the bills firmly
secured inside watch this boom there's
the credit cards pop right out
pop right in did I show my cars I don't
think yeah make sure you show this yeah
my credit cards that's it it's super
lightweight it's super durable um it's
it's just Fenton this is a fantastic
wall what can I say it's light sleek
industrial it doesn't fold or awkwardly
budge bulge in your pocket and it's
seriously changing the whole pocket
situation most people are still using
walls designed in the 90s carrying
around old receipts gift cards hotel
keys that's true hotel Keys is the worst
look I like ten of them in my wallet and
unorganized mess so let me tell you
about the ridge that holds up to twelve
cards plus room for cash there's over 30
colors and styles including carbon fiber
and burnt titanium I prefer my titanium
burn it's just a funny don't you think
that's a funny name burn titanium it's
pretty it's pretty descriptive anyway I
really love it I do but don't take my
word for it they have thirty thousand
five-star reviews the durable material
means each wallet comes with a lifetime
warranty you could buy this one wallet
and carry it for life the ridge team is
so confident that you'll like it and
that you'll let you test drive it for 45
days Wow
and you could send it back for a full
refund if you don't love it that's
incredible 45 day money back guarantee
make sure you include a text overlay on
the day that's a Dan a note for you to
include a text overlay of the discount
code what is the discount code it is a
stage-three go to Ridge comp / h3 and
news code h3 to get 10% off today with
the free worldwide shipping and return
so guys to get 10% off today with free
worldwide shipping and returns go to
rage comm slash h3 and use code h3 my
dudes the link is in the description
thank you so much - rich for sponsoring
us beautiful I have some bad news
our boy friend of the show Big Ed is
getting crushed
and social media now I got a iíve spoken
very fondly about this show before the
90 days I love it and poor Big Ed he's
getting creamed on social media man you
know his his plotline is good and we met
Big Ed before I even knew anything about
him all I knew is that the dude put
mayonnaise in his hair and we put
mayonnaise in Zach's hair and it was a
it was a great moment I loved having him
and I hope we can have him on again soon
we're trying to get did you hear back
from uh TLC the publicist not yet you
know he's got these handlers man they're
stay keep they keep heed on its short
leash bro yeah Zach reached out to ed
directly he texted him and apparently
the publicist got angry we're not
supposed to go direct to the end yeah he
you know last week said it was fine you
know had a great conversation and then I
text them and he's Allah everything sir
TLC now yeah Ted it must be it must be a
wild card for them you know he's a
little out there but but so there's this
there's this one specific video all
everybody's talking about ed on the
internet millions and millions of it
even PewDiePie made a video about the
mayonnaise [ __ ] but there's this one
specific video that was trending was
like number two or three trending on
YouTube what were you gonna say about
bigoted Eddard I I wonder if this show
has ever been so viral before this it
seems like more than ever yeah I think
this specific season just has so much
phenomenal yeah story arcs oh and then I
saw another headline the guy who's going
when to Ukraine to get the girl
he got kicked off the show he got and I
just saw the headline and I was super
excited to read it but I got distracted
and I forgot to read it so I don't know
what happened but apparently they would
the tell all episode they do at the end
of the season he's not allowed on it oh
I was I remember he he's married he's
what what what
read what yeah so we went to meet this
girl
and Ukraine no and he was like he he was
all about her cuz she was talking to
other American dudes on this whatever
dating site and it turns out not only is
he a ex-con for selling drugs he's
married he's actually married
how does that make sense Zack can you
look that up for me
type mug I think he might be David no
David yeah and by the way this guy has
these nipple tats that are next-level
you guys got to see these where are you
talking about that guy yeah yeah okay
okay wait I thought you're talking about
the guy in Vegas no no no no that guy's
married yeah he's married that doesn't
make sense
look at this look at this [ __ ] look at
his tats bro he is he is like tribal or
flame what is that what do you call that
is that the worst tattoo ever I mean
that's gotta be one of the worst tattoos
ever he's got tattoos around his nipples
that look like wait you're talking about
the not the guy that got catfished right
yeah I went to Ukraine to the guy who
who was the ex-con oh okay what okay
what's happened to him he got kicked off
the show tell me what happened look that
up anyway here to feast your eyes on his
nibs either tell me does that do
anything for you sounds like you don't
hate it though I'm saying well I don't
wanna I mean compared to the stuff we've
seen here on this show you really you're
not gonna disparage nipple tats I don't
like it
you want to suck on his nipples oh hey I
didn't realize I better get some nipple
tats quite please don I just learned
either likes nipple tats
his name's Jeffrey Jeffrey yes so so was
he kicked off the show that's what I saw
in the headline hold on anyway let's
what let's let's watch so big edie big
head has been through a lot of
controversies on the show I'm sad to say
first concert
merci was he asked rose to shave her
legs very he's insensitive he said he
goes your legs look like mine and I'd
like you to shave them and then they're
doing you know they do the confessionals
away from the partner he goes it's gross
so I think that rubbed people the wrong
way then a separate incident he told her
she had bad breath and he gave her
mouthwash and she's like I also have a
condition but also you presented it as a
gift like he was like I got you all this
gifts well it was all mouth related it
was toothbrush toothpaste and mouthwash
like I got you a really nice gift and so
he's he's constantly embarrassing her
the other one there's so many great
moments with Big Ed if I'm being honest
there was another great moment where
they want to see monkeys they went on a
vacation this this one I have I have to
admit this this was a little effed up
she's there with her son and she wants
him to spend time with her and her son
but he wants to spend time without the
Sun and so he kind of he kind of makes
her leave her son to go on this vacation
okay they go on the vacation and then
they toured this island with monkeys on
it and the monk and the monkeys start
freaking him out
he gets so scared of the monkeys I guess
one of the monkeys like took ice cream
from him and he got all scared it was
funny
and then finally the the big moment
comes when edy who is in his 40s I
believe he's 54 54 so ed is 54 yet he's
dating a like 22 year old and she is
she's been very upfront with as she says
I want two kids that's my dream is to
have two kids and Edie says you know I
don't want to have any kids well at
first he didn't say anything even though
she said that she wants more kids and
only Danny confronted her
at the very end of the trip at the end
of the trip he says I was planning to
get a vasectomy and I don't want kids
she goes well maybe that's something you
can think about he says I have nothing
to think about I don't want kids now
also he describes it as a little
snip-snip yeah even though he
understands English I found yeah yeah so
90-day fiance that rumors claim Geoffrey
was banned from tell or Union Telus ODEs
around the corner apparently spores have
been revealed current season and a
fiance many aren't happy with the
casting here we go he failed the I guess
the production didn't know of his
criminal records severe there were I've
tried to remove Geoffrey from the show
due to his lengthy criminal record but
it's lengthy TLC didn't catch wind of
the charges until they already filmed
the season wait so it's lengthy because
so I know he went to jail for selling
drugs he admits to her it's not kind of
effed up though they used the footage of
him and then they kick him off the towel
how kind of crap is that
what's why bad did at that point he can
be in the last episode if he's already
in the show right there's something else
he like killed someone apparently he
sorry he's been accused of raping and
attacking one of his ex-wives Levi's
bloodied in their home fans already
questioned how he passed the background
chips checks aren't able to grant it
Ibiza oh my god bro I would I wouldn't I
think that's probably a little more
severe than dealing drugs that's pretty
sad because they actually sound like
they were really bonding as a real
couple
I was like I was like why is this dude
going to Ukraine to find a bride now I
know why yeah so he's accused of keeps
going I'm reading about it too this just
like keeps going this is the nipple task
by the way go ahead Dan right yeah I
guess he was also
he's been married four times it sounds
like and yeah most recently in 2014 it
would appear and there's some stuff with
that and then in June of 2019 so just
last summer he was arrested for
assaulting his then-girlfriend
match these two up how are they airing
this because the mom did like he's up
there and she's like you gotta tell my
mom that you went to jail for selling
drugs and then the moms like I don't
trust him you know I don't want it but
the dude TLC is fit this dude got
arrested for beating his girlfriend last
summer well they claim they didn't know
the criminal charges yeah and apparently
they started filming only like a month
after that so he was basically arrested
but he was talking about his background
and it sounded like okay like he's known
drugs but he moved on and sounded like
it was a long time ago so I was drug
selling whatever but yeah and it sounds
like he has multiple assaults and
domestic evil if they're willing to
chaperone this relationship with this
poor Ukrainian girl's gonna move to
United States she's gonna be fully
dependent on him stuck there
and he know they're not letting him be
part of the reunion they already he's
already part of the show you're not
saying no but they're probably not gonna
continue with the 90 day actual this
shows so [ __ ] like they find the most
bunch of people is this before the 90
day they broadcast them on the world
stage and someone like big Edie is now
and like this guy it's just being
trashed on the world stage you nothing
can prepare you for the amount of [ __ ]
you get from God I don't know why
anybody goes on this show nobody has
come out of this alive
big edit like okay I mean I guess let's
just watch this video actually we don't
even need to wash it let's just read the
comments you know because bighead goes
because I watch them just they're gonna
like block my video they're ruthless
I don't know are you guys there's a new
thing on YouTube I'm not even gonna
claimed they just block your [ __ ]
video and I the whole video is just
blocked it Kevin
watch it I've been complaining to
YouTube about this I'm like look I don't
even mind getting claimed I have
sponsors I don't care about getting
claimed and you block and you block it I
can't work I can't make a show this is
insane
I don't know why companies do that she's
evil man [ __ ] you TLC I love your
content I hate that there could there's
evil they have to be they have to be
anyway he goes look I don't want kids
and she's like basically Edie you
embarrassed me you humiliate me you only
tell me now after all of this you knew I
wanted kids now you're telling me you
don't want kids after you slept exactly
and basically she's like [ __ ] you I'm
done and it was just one of those
moments where every one of the theaters
like you go girl you know what I mean
um so big ad is is on this let's read
some comments here
it's okay Rose I believe you'll find
better next next time there's a lot of
comments about of the neck and I have to
say that I don't approve of those it has
the maturity of a five-year-old and we
just not going to talk about that neck
boy every cut I didn't expect the next
[ __ ] I'm only reading what's here you
can only imagine yes please leave her
he's so freakin disgusting and not just
physically he's even uglier on the
inside shake my head I don't know how
they edit this show though it to be I
mean just to speak at least devil's
advocate on behalf of Edie you know I
don't know how they edit it cuz they've
always at every turn edits just look
like the biggest Duke this
and I'm sure he must have had some good
moments that's true make it seem like
there's no not even one good moment yeah
like he went to visit her dad's pig farm
and he was just like such a buffoon he
was like slipping in the mud and ever
you know I feel like the guy must have
had a good moment Wow
I want so badly to call him a disgusting
Pig but then I would feel bad for pigs I
can't get over this story about Geoffrey
yeah I know I was starting to get really
invested in their relationship and also
I thought like her mom was overreacting
right I did too and everyone was
overreacting he doesn't strike me as a
as a spousal abuse er but I guess you
never know he strikes me as an
unpredictable person he seems like he's
crazy he also said I come with baggage
and I was like I wasn't sure what he
must flame tattoos on his nipples he's
very soft-spoken and feminine so I
honestly thought he was gay at first but
I guess I don't know man
that was dude you got a watch you just
have to watch this show I can't even get
it to Hugo I want to watch this clip so
bad and what do I do
I'm afraid we get blocked should I just
watch it it will it will definitely get
blocked like a test fit it's so unfair
I could have talked to you about it this
oh and finally thank you to hims for
sponsoring us you've heard me talk about
him stand how they're helping guys look
their very best and if you haven't yet
it's time to see what they're all about
hymns did you guys know that 66% of
men's start to lose their hair by age 35
66 % Pam once you've noticed hair
thinning it's already too late is that
hair line slowly starting to move
backwards do you have any bald spots yet
well the best way to prevent more hair
loss is to do something about it
dagnabbit what is dagnabbit was it meant
is it like a it's like a parody of good
like what Yosemite Sam would say
what is it a meme was dag nagged a bit
nag dab nag at me I don't know what that
is the best way to prevent more hair
loss is to do something about it while
you still have it so why do you guys
turn to weird solutions or do nothing
when you can turn them science and
medicine introducing for hemes calm the
one-stop-shop for hair loss skin care
sexual wellness for men it's time to
write a new chapter one what you have
hair thanks to science baldness is now
optional this is not a snake pill or gas
station counter supplement this is
prescriptions backed by science and
doctors hims was created by guys to know
that some men's health conversions are
easier online that in-person we got no
more awkward and doctor visits or long
Pharmacy lines for hims connects you to
real doctors online which could save you
hours you simply complete a confidential
and discreet form and you answer a few
questions and a doctor reviews it
determines if it's right for you and
could prescribe you the medicine to
treat your hair loss that's shipped
directly to your door right now for our
listeners you get a free month for free
first month free go to forums calm /h 3
as for him for hims dot-com slash h3
prescription requires an online
consultation with a physician who will
determine if the prescription is
appropriate all for valid only if
prescribed 3 month minimum subscription
additional restrictions apply see
website for full detail and important
safety information remember that's for
hems com / h3
thank you for hims like to know the
entomology of DAG nabbit now yeah please
apparently is a it's just a censored way
of saying god dammit it's like the word
Nats cramp because people were afraid
you said god damnit that's you know you
get cursed yeah yeah exactly
it's dag
well it's not the same but it's like
it's it's got the same backwards within
hey instead of oh oh yeah exactly rabbit
dagnab use that a damn it dagnab you
I've been putting this video off for so
long we have to watch it Skippy Scott
bless Skippy the virgin
still a virgin by the way it still
doesn't masturbate the guy doesn't have
got him on a call though to watch this
but so it is so life is he went to
Cannes Film Festival no he did he said
it every time Bush won Sundance what's
the difference you can't assign France
was in Utah he went a Sundance Film
Festival and he got a bunch of
celebrities you know he's like obsessed
with celebrities and this is his thing
as he goes to Sundance and just stalks
them it's awesome and he got a bunch of
them to give a shout out to our show so
without further ado I give me skip man
harassing celebrities for seven minutes
straight for our show to promote Oh
shucks so from from Always Sunny okay
would you say hi this is Kaitlyn and
like subscribe to the there's some deep
cuts james Van Der Beek Oh II didn't
realize that was two words Van Der Beek
bro how you get four words in your name
james van der beek dirt that's a word
derp I'm guess I'm late to the I'm late
on this one everybody knew that is that
not funny to you list he's got a word in
his name this dirt van hey Dan back me
up third all right moving on thanks
James English Skippy
Podcast they've got six million
subscribers No would you say that
tougher tree there this video makes me
feel very very not it's at all in
perspective yeah he burns a shoe buggers
no no oh by the way skip you such a
legend he he uh he did a whole printout
of things he wanted them to say
laminated it and so he gives them
dislike menu what looks like a diner
menu of talking points thank you thank
you his publicist sorry about that
Audrey Audrey Blondo seen you play
basketball I was watching my friends no
nude friends and so I watched you with
the pistol shrimps good small talks oh I
know thank you Joe no filming and I was
here when you had mystery team to miss
the shut up my friend Oh
lin-manuel Miranda
[Music]
with the flames my friends on the h3
podcast thank you
I'm actually I'm surprised people so
willing to give shout outs the shows
they don't know cuz I could be a white
nationalist for all they know gonna be a
show about yeah I think we left it in
there's a couple that that have that
they're like no I don't know who that is
I'm not saying that yeah if somebody
asked me to endorse something I didn't
know right some people actually say
watch the h3 podcast and then I mean
look I'm not you know I mean I guess if
it's meant to you ask but I don't think
I am oh this guy actually knows who we
are Marcus Wright I'm sorry I don't know
who he is though does anyone know who
Marcus tribe shrubner is to see a
picture of him not a Greek he's from a
show called black-ish a blackish
fantastic what up Marcus that we get to
see people say no well Farrell here's a
big shot let's see how he responds
that's it
and will you say hi to my friends I h3h
oh yeah dude it's [ __ ] strider h3h3
their podcast with 6 million subscribers
well what is it about okay thanks
see ya smart you don't want to adorn
somebody I wish we had double shopping
Jesse and bonus a hug my friends a free
podcast there there a podcast with a few
million let me just say like it's so
humiliating tough to do this
like I actually podcast you know what I
mean don't you feel 2 million for them
yeah no okay
heist 3 podcast how are you thank you so
much Jude Law podcast Jude Law I would
totally take his dick in my but uh look
how pale he mean he's dressed
till we got a shut up from Jude Law
podcast Jerry Juhl Akkad spitting
tomorrow Jerry minor right I'm Skippy we
met in LA when I first moved there you
were like the first one I met I love it
old friend
oh I got you guys yo you remember me
we met in LA and he says I've never been
that way did he say you're not Jerry did
he mistake him for someone else
Ian cuz you edited this right because he
said you're not cheering
Ian what is this you mistook him for
someone else
yeah I cut off pretty quick that's
awesome
how long was the original video cuz this
one seven minutes in 20 minutes I think
it was about maybe an hour 15 wait was
it just not edited at all just a whole
yeah just be him walking for like ten
minutes then but it was edited it was
edited yeah I was about to say now it
there was a lot of just like extra [ __ ]
in there too but that hour and a half
was already cut down so though so but
can we just appreciate that he just
mistook this random black dude for
another black dude Jerry minor and he
says you're not sure there you met and
then thank you thank you do that my
friends on the h3 how do your friends at
age three podcast thank you thank you
see ya Thank You publicist I appreciate
you Crawford thank you is that the guy
they make a bunch of creams videos and
stuff like that I'm the real like 40
year old virgin they make my video
sombrio we skip you out here enough
times people are gonna start to remember
us for not the right reason people
remember the h3 is stuck in their head
man then all the sudden Alison Brie gets
a message from publicist h3 she's like
I'm average three where have I heard
that before
Skippy the virgin yada yada yada our
show's huge
again you guys I'm not gonna harass you
just gonna say hi he does they think
it's a photo but the video okay well you
say how you my friends on the h3h3
podcast hi to your friends on the h3
what is it
h3 podcast how do your friends at the
eight-three party thank you I'll let you
go I have to say I didn't say yeah you
are last time you were here you were at
the Operation Smile ski race and that
was last time I saw you so thank you for
something and will you say hi to my
friends from h3 h3
I too will your friends from h3 h3 he's
praying this if he does have a knife on
him I could tell Paul Bettany I love
when it goes I've met you before
okay you have a knife on you doing Jim
Gaffigan looks like Skippy but like Jim
looks like Skippy dad or like it's uncle
or some [ __ ] and Jim goes how many times
have we met here like they're old
friends say hi to my friends at the h3
h3 podcast and you say go watch hit or
go watch the h3 h3 podcast podcast
Anne Hathaway he starts by saying I owe
you an apology
what can be done - Hannah hey sweater
does anyone ever call your lawyer like I
should be watching too bad for her we're
white nationalists and she does endorse
no Nazis hey Zack can I get a good one
with you who's I get a good one with you
oh he's running up to the car window and
the window is not going down
he's thank you I didn't get a good
perfect
thank you thanks guys bye sorry woods I
love he doesn't know that are you from
okay okay
thank you Carrie Brownstein who did the
names was it you you nor Skippy I did
the ones I knew and then Skippy gave us
some more okay well that was fantastic
reporting from Skippy at the at the
river dance why do you call it the river
dance
yeah that's it Riverdance thank you -
Skippy that was a fantastic reporting
I'd love to send Skippy you know be the
best the sense get me to like a porn
convention wouldn't that be the greatest
on field reporting ever I don't think
he'd be up for it though something tells
me like someone bad depraved of sexual
like stimulus you know congratulations
to Elon Musk and Grimes the arrival of
their new baby boy named X a X ie a 12
now I know it's ash but saying ash
doesn't do justice now where'd it is
congratulations to their baby boy ex ash
a 12
who will definitely be super stoked that
they named him that throughout his
entire life I think they'll probably
just call him ash though or I'll go by
ex Professor X X is it kind of a dope
name ax yeah I like X that's a weird one
man Ilan this she was tweeting from the
hospital the explanation for the baby's
name X the unknown variable AE ash my
elven spelling of AI love or artificial
intelligence
what's Elvan about it is that an Elvin
character okay a 12 Knowles aren't real
so no try telling that to a X ash a 12 a
12 is the precursor to the SR 17 our
favorite aircraft why not just do use SR
17 if that's your favorite aircraft y
812 no weapons no defense just speed
great in battle but nonviolent and the a
of course stands for arc angel and then
Elon a corrector he says sr-71 but yes
and she responded I am recovering from
surgery and barely alive so may my typos
be forgiven but damn it that was meant
to be profound I couldn't tell if they
were if this was they must have just
been goofing around right yeah I have to
let's assume that for the sake of young
X ash a 12 let's see on Joe Rogan Elon
was recently on Brogan man I gotta turn
my adblock home the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
trying to do a show here
yeah how do you say the name first of
all my partner's the one that actually
mostly came up with the name
congratulations to her yeah yeah she's
very named so I mean it's just X the
letter X and then the AE is like
pronounced ash well a12 is my
contribution oh ye 12 Archangel 12 the
precursor to the sr-71 coolest plane
ever I appreciate the show I mean it's
fun it's a little kooky so I appreciate
you just being upfront about that but
anyway congratulations to them that was
and all the news X is kind of a dope
nape and so is ash though so I have a
feeling he's not gonna go by X ash a 12
so probably should they'll probably
abbreviate that oh did you guys monk
monkeys are brazii out here boy this
videos been making its rounds in this is
some nightmare fuel because well first
of all Gila I didn't know that monkeys
were this powerful you can see it's a
small monkey you haven't watched enough
joe rogan then hey you're talking about
he always talks about gorillas right or
knows you talk about monkeys I guess it
is mostly gorillas but no it's just
monkeys in general this little monkey
comes charging down the street and
Facebook kidnaps I was gonna bike - it's
a [ __ ] crazy any pulled up and then
he takes this girl like why does the
monkey have bicycle and why was this guy
filming this guy this monkey comes
bombing down the street on a bike okay
then he grabs the girl tries to take off
with that oh what the [ __ ]
[Music]
he's so strong cuz cuz the girls bigger
than the monkey that the girls probably
like maybe three years old I don't know
maybe older what she was staying by
surprised no but once she hit the ground
was in surprise me that he took her out
because he took her out and she hit the
ground but then he grabbed her and
dragged her ass like 20 feet that's what
shocked me you know [ __ ] you let's
suggest that we skip that video but I
insisted we watch it I didn't like it he
was like we need to watch this I was
like are you crazy it's one of those
videos that if you're not if you're like
only listening you won't get it but I
was wrong well your prop well the people
listening are like no you weren't wrong
the unites this is a good one the United
States quarter Twenty twenty quarter has
on the back of it bats
nice timing on that one be how do I get
one it's kind of cool actually no that's
a collectible
remember the coronavirus collectible
quarters minted by the US government in
memory of the coronavirus coronavirus
apparently it was put in honor to to
honor the Americans Pacific island
territory which features a cheerful
looking mama fruit bat and her pup now
that's the bat to start a coronavirus
that's funny
where do you buy quad which is a
cross-border so is this just in
circulation this is just the quarter you
just asked how much it costs to buy a
quarter well I don't know if it's like a
collectible or if this is just like
general circulation this is just the new
quarter yeah well they do because they
sell dollar coins like on TV you can buy
this one dollar coin for twenty dollars
right okay
they put them in sets threw them in so
like the of sterling silver ones and
stuff like that so you could pay upwards
of twenty-five dollars for a quarter
there you go you see I'm not I'm not
stupid
Thank You Zack well apparently if you
just go anybody who's paying $25 for a
quarter his stupid though can we agree
on that
I don't know I'd collect coins dan what
are you trying to say what you say Zack
I said I collect coins and then you
don't really maybe yeah oh look I'm the
mint what's your most valuable quarter
worth how much would you pay for this
coin I don't know I don't have valuable
coins I have valuable dollar bills like
I have a 19 1934 $10 bill but back when
they had like the silver so you get
silver and gold for it when they stuff
the gold standard that was the yeah I
know about that because in 1934 was the
last year they actually made them out of
silver I remember well the 1933 Double
Gold Eagle coin which they made illegal
and I think FDR made of me legal there's
something like that so back in the day a
dollar was worth so much that they
actually made them out of silver and the
value was equal now obviously the silver
is worth way more than a dollar and I
remember I went to the bank I still
always go to the bank as a kid and get
silver dollars in the hope that I got
one of these older air ones and lo and
behold it's so crazy I actually got one
from the bank that was from 1934 that
was made of silver oh and my dad my dad
couldn't believe it because my dad was
somewhat of a coin collector
was a very rare coin was worth like a
couple hundred bucks and my dad goes he
get he's like I'll give you five bucks
for a box I kept the money for himself
all right just another great story of my
dad ripping his own son off but how
crazy is that that the bank actually
gave me a silver dollar that's pretty
cool how about that for a story huh
fantastic next week on coin facts the
podcast a year
[Laughter]
this headline kind of shipped me to my
core Tom Cruise is collaborating with
NASA to shoot a movie in space Tom
Cruise is going to space to shoot a
movie does this not incredible to you
guys and NASA is excited to work with
Tom Cruise on a film aboard the space T
he's actually going on the space station
it's pretty badass
the reason being they said we need
popular media to inspire a new
generation of engineers and scientists
to make NASA ambitious plans a reality
that's actually a really good cause but
what what I wonder is I feel like
filming and space probably is gonna be
more difficult than just and probably
look weirder than just filming it in a
in a studio like they've gotten so good
at it now when I see movies that are
supposed to be in space like there was
that recent one with Christopher Nolan
[Music]
inner stone
yeah interstellar it's gotten so good
that it's like I wonder it's gonna be
this has to be really challenging to
actually shoot in space thoughts Danny
yeah yeah I I'm very curious what
exactly this is gonna be I imagine it it
it's not gonna be a whole movie that
they shoot up there it's probably just a
few scenes from it or something but
what's interesting is it's like I know
it costs an immense amount of money to
send some lay to space so are they just
sending Tom and if so does that mean
like the
astronauts on the space station are
going to be the cameramen for these are
they sending up a felt route I I would
guess this gonna send one one cameraman
be the director it's gonna be really
interesting because it's so real and
you're gonna feel it
however it's gonna be eyes impressed
yeah I actually I disagree a little bit
with wait like a certainly the
technology has come to such an extent
that in movies like interstellar it's
quite believable but when you look at
footage of people actually floating
around in space it it's it's impossible
to actually reproduce the effect of
zero-gravity like what that looks like
with people's limbs kind of floating off
in weird directions it's still I haven't
seen it simulated to a hundred percent
yet so you know I mean is it worth it to
go through all this trouble to do it
maybe maybe not like you're right it's
you can get it in a studio close enough
that it's fine but it sounds like
there's ulterior motive here it is to
you know promote the space program and
everything so well that's it if that's
the goal then yeah yeah
certainly it's cool I'm I'm I'm super
looking forward to seeing how that comes
out yeah that's super cool it's feels
exciting like in a way that you don't
really see anymore where something is
like whoa like that's unthinkable baby
Tom Cruise we're gonna this is the this
is how this meeting went in Hollywood
we're gonna take Tom Cruise and we're
gonna put him in space actual space I'm
in who's how we gonna watch this though
nobody the movie theaters are done
straight to Netflix I guess this is
probably a long ways out if they're just
announcing it now I mean these space
missions get planned a years in advance
right so
in space on the International Space
Station that's so cool
anyway congratulations Tom Cruise
Scientology made this happen you know it
is mine everything like this just
justifies his I hope not man that's is
you got to put your foot down on that
[ __ ] we get sin Scientologist to space
we have to keep all the Scientologists
with that with Tom Cruise being the one
exception out of space shredder you know
what confused me I kept seeing this
story about the UFOs but we had a whole
segment talking about this this the
whole video was going viral recently
yeah it's it's it's become viral again
because now it was officially released
by the military whereas before I believe
it was leaked and like sort of pseudo
confirmed by the military that it was
authentic but now now it's been like
officially I guess and so it's kind of
doing a second round so I'm confused
because here it says the following video
clips were Declassified by the Navy the
Defense Department said the video show
unidentified aerial phenomena but when
we interviewed Mick West he claimed that
it was like really just ordinary [ __ ]
like lens flares or whatever or the
reflection of a plane or some some
mundane explanation but the Navy is
saying that it was aerial phenomena so
for them to say that kind of gives
credence to the theory that this yeah
that's pretty insulting yeah yeah I mean
yeah Mick when he was breaking it down I
mean he's doing it as a lay person that
just sort of has a skeptical mind when
they're trying to come up with other
explanations but yeah I mean
with them coming out and outright saying
they don't know what it is hard to argue
with that it's really interesting with
the dialogue
in a statement the Defense Department
said it was releasing the video in order
to clear up any misconceptions by the
public on whether or not the footage
that has been circulating was real I
really don't know I love that they say
it's it I love that they say it's to
clear up confusion and their way of
clearing up confusion is coming out and
confirming that it is indeed a UFO
without any other like follow-up
statement I feel like that creates more
confusion right I am confused it's
saying Harry Potter Day aerial
phenomenon
them calling it an aerial phenomena
definitely doesn't it sounds like it
that's them saying this is something we
that we can't explain what it is for
sure yeah I mean yes in essence I mean
it doesn't mean that it's alien laughs
it just it means that they don't know
what it is what if aliens are just
cruising around a little but if they
really like traveling some kind of
aircraft don't you think we'll have like
real actual footage that is just so
clear yes I do I just wonder why it's
always this little dot that's my problem
with this every time there's a UFO or
alien or an unexplainable thing it's
always some blurry ass dot and you know
why is because once it becomes into
focus you know what it is and it doesn't
become an issue it's only when it's a
blurry little dot that it's interesting
right it's not a blurry dot then you
don't even hear about it because it's
not interesting or it could just be that
they're using advanced covenant cloaking
technology like in the video game series
halo halo we heard a halo I have heard
of halo but this one's a little out but
that's a thermal imaging so maybe
they're just seeing the thermal
signature but it's in fact using some
sort of cloaking device which is why it
can't be seen by the naked eye you think
about that yes are you
mind blown yeah my I played a lot I
played a lot of healing so I know a
thing or two about cloaking devices
that's what it looks like watch Star
Trek though oh so much Star Trek yeah
nice yeah it's a Romulan cloaking device
but I would get if it is aliens I would
say it's a little robot probably
unmanned you know sending out explorers
but some people say that the the grey
aliens you know some people say that the
grey aliens are just sort of biological
drones that are being remotely
controlled by beings in another star
system or whatever sorry what do we talk
about you know what greys are no what is
a grey alien the grazier it's the name
for just those stereotypical aliens that
you always see with the big eyes there
yes exactly I comb grays oh yeah that's
right so they're being remote controlled
by other more L am looking aliens
all right let's wrap it's just that's
what I've read that's what I've read how
long we've been going because we because
it's hard I have no I started so many
times probably about an hour and a half
today was a very messy episode and I
keep going I got more [ __ ] I think corn
thing is getting in our heads is that
are you guys starting to feel really
tired all the time yes it's the
quarantine I think I think it's a lack
of sunshine at least in my case so I've
been trying to force myself outside to
walk the dogs or something but I feel
like that doesn't help it's just the
being at home all the time yeah yeah I
went one day to the office this week to
review some 35 samples and it felt so
good just getting dressed while doing
something see other people I think you
gotta force yourself to we kept social
distancing in a man
but it's securing and getting to me
yeah the other day I just went for a
drive for like an hour
which is actually really nice to do now
because there's no traffic in LA which
is not normal and so I was able to I
drove like all the way across town and
back without really a destination in
mind in about an hour yeah that circuit
would take like four hours on a normal
day so he started out loving drives and
then he started to hate them and now
he's going back to loving the drives
maybe you should I feel like I just it
made me so much lazier because like I'm
so I'm the less active I am make the
more lazy I become lethargic I become
actually was really getting into
exercising before quarantine started
that's right all right ice a week and it
made me feel better my back pain was
getting less frequent and now I'm just
my body just feels like it's about to
break I need to do the bike I want to do
it every morning but I can't every
morning then I've have trouble sleeping
lately you know it's a whole mess I mean
God you really don't help yourself when
it's like 1:30 and instead of going to
sleep you're like okay I'm going to play
video games yeah but I'm not tired
what's your problem it doesn't help to
go and play it's like 1025 I'm ranked
like 116 oh yeah what's going on without
freedo good he's so fluffy because I
surgery alright now we can
we need this kid job but no he is
unrecognizable are there dog groomers
over right now my dog that's so bad it
could be opening soon right aren't they
supposed to be lifting the some of the
restrictions today yeah although today
dog groomers probably weren't uh yeah
that's some some clothing stores okay
they need their anal glands expressed
did I tell the story how I got you to
say milk no I said you gotta call the
back you say Express but it milks and
will you milk my anal gland Adam Eve uh
calm she's caught h3 so much I wasn't
sure about rescuing a dog or adopting a
dog I never rescue him but he's so nice
he's so sweet it's just like the
sweetest most loving dog ever I'm so
happy that he's part of it makes this
cuddle noises oh yeah he's like exhaling
loudly out of his nose all right speak
in the mic alright we've we've lost the
plot here look plot
so quarantine yeah
guys thank you for watching if you're
still with us remember when we used to
do the podcast from the office yeah I
know I kind of Miss that it's nice to be
in there feels so official and you're
like there you're working and you guys
are there and you can see what the [ __ ]
I'm talking about
you can't see what I'm talking about now
all right yeah I mean I follow along as
best I can but yeah it's a it's a little
awkward doing a nice but I don't like
seeing your faces to be frank either
because I don't like seeing your face
either
well Oh in the podcast room it's just me
and Ella and I like it because now when
I say something distract and I said oh
dude those guys think it was funny yeah
and I look at you guys that nobody's
even cracking a smile so maybe we should
minimize duh I was wondering if we even
need to have it open also I find but
that if we do talk to her just minimize
because I find myself looking here a lot
when I should be right you got the
camera as well when you're recording why
just put it behind another window though
put it by another window dance a piece
of the truth dance piece to truth to
power surge an coronavirus corona corona
virus by the way cops are Trump's so
pence head of chief of staff got tested
positive for Corona I read it the vice
president and then Trump's one of trumps
chauffeurs got tested positive one of
the private drivers and those guys are
walking around without masks and [ __ ] I
feel like there's a good chance all
those guys are gonna catch the corona
virus get it real I think they should be
more careful it's kind of crazy to see
like the president not wearing a mask
because I keep hearing about people not
wearing masks outside and it's just lame
you just put on a mask
well actually I will say that so there's
a there's a convenience store at the gas
station nearby or
house and throughout this pandemic I've
gone there several times in the
beginning middle and end the beginning I
went there no it was the Wild West
nobody was social distancing the cashier
didn't have gloves on I mean it was just
it was scary the second time people were
wearing some people wearing gloves and
masks and the cashier was all gloved and
masked up I went there yesterday they
have plastic installed at the cashier
they have a social distancing like check
marks so when you're standing online
you're 6 feet apart and every single
person in there had a mask on so I will
say that here in California in Los
Angeles based on just that one location
that people are doing very well doing a
very good job there I felt much safer
there the last time I went that being
said with the President and Vice
President walking around without max I
mean how can they expect anyone to take
it seriously when they themselves are
not leading by example the president's
cruising route thought a mask why should
anyone look at him be like well why the
[ __ ] should I wear a mask I don't get it
I mean I don't understand why him and
the Vice President walk around without
masks it just it strikes me as so
bizarre I don't get it
let me Trump toward a mask factory a
literal mask factory without a mask and
I saw in the news today he was visiting
with that was just the other day wasn't
it yeah that was like a day or two ago
yeah and now a bunch of their staff is
testing positive for right exactly so
Trump may actually have been maybe
infected it's possible and he's going
about like when that have contaminated
the whole factory like the the people
making well I don't think it would be
ironic though about breaking a mask
factory no wearing a mask cuz if you're
not wearing it you're risking the I
don't know how you're exactly and dude
it's your you're the president right
it's your recommendation you're the one
that that sponsors the CDC
recommendation okay if you don't want
people to wear masks they
just say that but you have you put out
the statement that people need to be
wearing masks in public and you're not
doing it I saw in the news today he was
visiting I [ __ ] you not with World War
two veterans without a mask he's
visiting at-risk War veterans and he's
not wearing a mask that's crazy I don't
understand this obsession with just not
wearing a mask I don't know what kind of
the message he's trying to send
I mean clearly it's a it seems I don't
know I don't know I just I don't know
dude I don't know bro this thing is out
of control in the United States and I
don't see it getting better I'm sorry
like it feels like other countries all
have got plans for getting back to
normal and it feels like currently here
is like just so far behind well they act
like okay we did the lockdown now let's
reopen that's true you're supposed and
during the lockdown you're supposed to
ramp up testing so that you can safely
reopen we don't have anywhere near
enough tests to safely reopen and many
of the states that are reopening they
have an ongoing a climbing infection
rate then you've got misinformation
you've got all these documentaries and
people coming out saying that the virus
is a conspiracy and that it has a lower
death rate than the flu and all this
nonsense you have people saying the
hospitals are empty I mean I don't know
what we're gonna do as a country because
there's no way that we're on top of this
pandemic there's just no way you they
people look at they go in South Korea
they're open yeah because they have
testing per capita out the ass and they
can safely test and trace infections we
have a huge population we have all these
different states the federal government
is not stepping up in an organized
central way and they're basically
passing the buck to the states which
means that when when Kansas doesn't shut
down and they have a climbing infection
rate California where we're only
as strong as our weakest link and
without a federal organized effort we're
all just gonna be [ __ ] and there's
still not enough testing it's crazy it's
crazy
I don't know my prediction right now cuz
they keep increased they're saying like
150,000 people gonna be dead by Jim dude
I don't know I feel like in the United
States short they saying that a vaccine
might be out in November that's
fantastic
that's incredible if that's true we
better be amazing we better [ __ ] pray
that's what will happen because that's
the only thing that's gonna get us here
in the United States out of this mess
there's some medicine that helps reduce
the duration of the illness which is
also really good news but ultimately we
as a country are not doing anywhere near
enough to stop this and I feel like it's
just going to be and obviously the
economic implications are tremendously
damaging I mean it's just it's
staggering the economic damage is is is
definitely is definitely gonna be worse
than than what the virus is doing but
you know I don't there's tons of
protests about reopen the economy and
frankly I don't even blame them because
what are they supposed to do they're
sitting at home they're not making money
they've got bills to pay they lost their
insurance it's like yeah these people
need to work they need to make money but
the government the thing is they're
blaming their miss their miss placing
their blame the government needs to be
doing more to help these people so that
they're not in such a dire situation
there need to be ramping up testing that
you'll be stepping up the social safety
net my parents for example they still
didn't get their their stimulus check
which is crazy
I was just casually talking in them and
about it because I was like hey do you
guys get your stimulus check and they
still haven't got it and I was like whoa
imagine actually you needing that money
I mean you'd be just [ __ ] by now
there's just not enough being done so I
sympathize tremendously with people
protesting but I think they're they're
they're really
they're kind of miss placing their blame
in my opinion I have a tremendous amount
of empathy for them you know can only
imagine how scary it is to lose your job
your health insurance and you got no
[ __ ] money and you can't go find a
job I mean it's horrifying
it's just awful but honestly until that
that vaccine comes out I think here in
America we're just not doing enough and
it's just a it's just gonna ravage us
until that vaccine comes out and we're
reopening
we're either we're gonna re close again
in like a month or two or this virus you
just gonna it's just gonna kill a
million people in the United States
bye-bye November by the time the or god
forbid even longer November cycle if it
comes out November that's like a miracle
of God so it could be longer I think I
think United States gonna eat [ __ ] big
time from this virus it sucks you know
it sucks man was totally preventable to
United States there was something wrong
with the test the test didn't work for
the whole like first month or the whole
beginning timeframe we were not doing
any tests and the virus was just running
wild during the first stages of the
beginning we could have stopped it
we could have mitigated a big time test
didn't work
we had tests that failed and way to
remake the test that's [ __ ] crazy and
then China by the way is now reporting
zero deaths zero like like almost no new
infections and they're all good China's
all good I knew this was gonna happen
China is all good I mean they say
they're all good they're all good
they're open I mean if they were if that
virus was still rampant you would see
the country closed you saw what happened
they closed the whole the quarantine 11
million people the country is open
everything's running over in China India
is about to get fisted by this virus
Mexico's about to get fisted by this
virus
[Music]
Russia is about to get fisted by this
virus it's actually people think that
we're like people think we're on the way
down this virus is just getting started
because in the United States in India in
Russia and Mexico this virus is about to
go ape [ __ ] and I frankly don't think
the United States can sustain another
lockdown people cannot tolerate another
lockdown you see how it's going up right
now yeah so what happened if you look at
the daily new cases in the United States
New York obviously was the epicenter of
the corona virus and it spread their way
faster than other parts of the country
because of the proximity of people
what's happening is in New York it's
going down a lot every day and then in
rural parts of the country where the
virus is spreading slower because it's
less populated it's starting to rise
exponentially there in rural parts and
incidentally the rural parts of the
country are the ones that are not for
the most part taking the necessary steps
either to mitigate so what you're gonna
see as New York is going to be going
down but in the rural areas you're gonna
start seeing a really dangerous spike in
cases you can see that it's spiking in
cases right now and it's it's I don't
know - I really don't know what's gonna
happen
I'm afraid the federal government is not
stepping up its duty - to - you need you
need a central role here we have 50
states each doing its own thing fighting
an open marketplace for protective gear
I don't get the approach I don't get it
this is what the federal government's
for a centralized effort between all
states to make a coordinate it's just I
don't get it
and it's say that the governor of New
York yeah he said that now they see less
new cases among actually the health work
and people first responders and stuff
and more outside and you said that's
actually a good thing because it means
that people who do follow the guidelines
I like wearing a mask but protecting
actually it works so he said that's a
good thing hmm I thought that was
interesting but we don't have enough of
the protective gear you know on the open
market and just being aware and at least
I mean being aware of it when you're
outside put something on and washing
your hands and all that stuff yeah yeah
yeah no it I did wearing a mask
definitely helps like if everyone's
wearing a mask it's got to cut down on
the spread a lot yeah and that's what's
so messed up is when you go outside
without a mask you're endangering other
people right so so when the president
walks outside and visits people without
a mask it's it's you're basically
telling the people that you're visiting
with that you're fine risking them yeah
I mean how do you I don't get it why
does he why doesn't he why is he so
opposed to wearing a mask I mean I know
that he's very particular about like his
hair and his makeup and stuff is it just
about his hair and makeup that he
doesn't want to look ridiculous I don't
know somehow in this country coronavirus
became a political topic well now well
it's not only a political topic now it's
just the conspiracy theory the intensity
of conspiracy theories has gotten so
crazy like there's there it's just it's
so intense the the the amount of
conspiracy theory talks and and that's
all I can say about that really I like I
like shoving this at the end because
nobody wants to hear me talk about her
own advice anymore but I'm very
concerned I'm following it closely and
gosh I really don't know what's gonna
happen here in the United States very
concerned and and like it's just
starting to really Pete exponentially
grow in India and Mexico
in Russia and those are just gonna be
devastating and North Korea North
Korea's I feel so bad for those poor
North Koreans North Korea is gonna be
ravaged ravaged ravaged by this didn't
have running water you know what I mean
like how you supposed to be hygienic
time gonna running water well it's gonna
be a long year guys it really is it's
gonna be a long year and the thing is
that now wouldn't you've got like 30
percent unemployment rate people still
have a little money in their pocket it
doesn't feel that bad right now cuz the
real depression hasn't hit us yet
because people still have a little bit
of money they still have a little bit of
hope they got this stimulus check most
people and but what's gonna happen is in
a month or two when those people's money
starts running out is when you're gonna
see real desperation and I really hope I
don't know I really don't know what's
gonna happen but we are not out of this
yet not even close and and I fear for
for our country but I'm hoping for the
best
I'm not saying right now we're doing
like 250,000 tests a day we need to be
doing like 5 million I heard to
adequately the test to safely reopen and
contact trace and all that 5 million
damn it's crazy
aw there's like a whole nother thing
with all these businesses closed then
all the states are like going bankrupt
because they rely on taxes sales tax
property tax all these taxes that people
are either deferring or outright people
aren't spending money they're not doing
this and doing that California I heard
for example last year we have like a 30
billion dollar surplus and now
California is at a 50 billion dollar
deficit just like that cuz you have to
buy all the protective gear you have to
buy all the tests you have to pay for
all the medical stuff and then meanwhile
you have no money coming in that's crazy
dude
I don't know what's gonna happen but the
good news is the stock markets going up
stock market continues to climb baby
we're almost back to where we started
explained that [ __ ] to me actually I
heard a good explanation finally
somebody's cuz I've been wondering what
the [ __ ] how was the stock market going
up
someone said here's the best explanation
of hurt 1 where else is people gonna put
their money that's number one - someone
said there's a big fear of missing out
where people don't want to miss the
opportunity to get in while on a good
deal on stocks and that those are the
two best reasons I've heard which
actually makes me scared that there's
gonna be a huge decline and people are
gonna get their [ __ ] I think if we ever
have to shut down again the market is
gonna crash so hard I'm very caught I
don't have any money in the market I'm
very cautious of it right now I don't
trust it cuz it's like a it's like a
it's like one bit when everyone was
talking about Bitcoin they're like to
just put my in it just goes up and up
and up
people are getting greedy about it and I
think that I I'm saying far away from
the stock market right now right now I
mean in general the stock market just
imaginary [ __ ] but I'm I'm just
saying like if we clock down again then
the markets gonna crash big-time any
other questions
anyone want my opinion on anything else
no Jesus my mic just literally guys
anything else you want me to talk about
go ahead well detour made ela her first
Mother's Day present it's the outline of
his hand and it's a happy Mother's Day
cute as [ __ ] yeah it's pretty cute well
speaking of Theodore I guess we'll go
spend some time with him now it's 3:20
he's gonna leave a couple hours so let's
do that
mmm-hmm thank you everybody for watching
ending on a high note and ding aha
I know Otto Trump removed any oversight
on all the stimulus money United States
government just gave out like two
trillion dollars with no oversight at
all
why is there no oversight on all the
true trillion dollars do you know who's
gonna get all the money a bunch of rich
corporations that already are rich and
don't need it and you know who's not
gonna get the money dudes in the line at
food banks
yeah no oversight how the [ __ ] you can
get about two trillion dollars and then
not have any oversight the [ __ ] destroy
the child who's gonna get all that money
apples like I'll take a trillion who's
gonna get all that cash and then five
Pfeifer is that the drug company they're
like we'll take it we'll take fifty
billion dollars thank you the CEO needs
a new yacht Yeah right
Yeah right Shake Shack returned their
stimulus money
yeah they got shamed into it but it's
not even the stimulus money they're
actually giving out crazy huge loans to
big so that the PPP's for small
businesses of under five hundred
employees but they're actually giving
out huge [ __ ] loans to big big big
big companies like the airline guy like
how much money to the airline's get like
goddamn billions and billions right
let's protest let's reopen the country
goddamn it
no test
did you guys get your stimulus check
yeah I did you out Zach did you get a
Simmons check yes they did not yet oh
you didn't get it well I care they don't
have my routing information okay
well that's cool I hope that $1,200 last
you during this whole pandemic Apple got
a Apple got um 10 trillion dollars they
just put it in their bank account it's
collecting interest they put it on an
offshore bank account so that'll help us
hey I'm just I don't know I just I don't
know why there's no oh you can end this
any time you who's gonna clip this and
then say Ethan's a Lib [ __ ] do but touch
kids what does the church do a little
devil sticks [ __ ] ends Joe no [ __ ] no
this is a good [ __ ] sign up for every
there's no one smiling at all on zoom'
there's no there's no joy on
Ian looks like a painting look at okay
let's just remain sign if everyone
remains silent for one minute we can end
it okay
dead air for one minute and then the
show's over
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]